I I realized that Shaytan is really you
know so I believed in God but I didn't
believe in Shaytan Shaytan like the
devil that's what we were playing funky
music and everything but there was I was
not happy when they were singing about
Jesus being God you know I was never
singing both songs when it was songs
about God I was singing with them but
when was Jesus being the Son of God I
was like now this is not right and ask
them where's the proof brother Julian
tell us in your quest now seeking to no
purpose what were some of the religions
that she went through and why did you
exclude those religions and choose Islam
okay so I was born in a Christian
country Catholic country in France and
then back in the nineties the Dalai Lama
and Buddhist was a big thing in France I
became I don't want to say I became
Buddhist but I was trying to pray and
meditate the way the bullies do I did
that for a while I even did attend a
meditation retreats right before
becoming Muslim our state practicing
attend a meditation retreat so you were
really into it
I was yeah you have to stop you you
don't talk to anybody during ten days
and you made it 810 hours it took off
huh yeah it's psychotic affair so you
just don't talk and your last meet is at
12 noon but it except we can talk though
yeah you can talk but not this type of
retreats and what about that other one
you took that you were telling about
that it's like a ha it's a garage yeah
so I did what we call the the pit we in
the way of Genesis it's the Christian
pilgrim because deep inside everyone
it's in our fitrat who wants to do a big
limb is that called the Christian then
they call it the Christian Hajj almost
like it's kind of back in the days they
used to have to they used to have Rome
people we used to be grim towards Rome
and now you still it's an ongoing thing
but even at least are doing it now
more like a cultural thing while you you
have to reach the west coast of Spain
and they believe one of the body of the
apostle's of Jesus one of the disciples
was a sip of Jesus body is there so
people from all over the world you can
even go for this is he wears it is it's
in Spanish in Spain right we're in Spain
it's in Santiago de Compostela it's in
in Galicia yeah in the province of
Galicia so I walked from the French
border 1000 kilometer the Heusen killing
me 30 days 30 days sometimes I walked 50
kilometers a day and I was trying to
find God I mean the purpose was to find
myself find God and it's only a few
years after that I became Muslim in in
the Philippines I also before that went
to Mexico to learn from the shamans you
know because in 2012 it was believed
that it will be the end of the world
yeah and I didn't really believe that
but I wanted someone somehow because I
was sick and tired of all these wars
hypocrisy so I was hoping for a change
so you're doing all you're doing the the
Buddhism whatever happened with the you
were doing the the Christianity you were
experimenting with that that's kind of
your roots so why did you leave your
roots and then go to Buddhism and then
go to all these other isms yeah because
there was no substance no substance in
Christianity my parents didn't believe
in it anymore and after I I realized so
my point is I realized that Shaitan is
real you know so I believed in God but I
didn't believe in [ __ ] and Shaitaan like
the devil that's really the devil so I I
realized my bootys and could not help me
because even in the top of a mountain it
can still mess me up you know so I
realized I need to go back to God so I
went back to Christianity I was about to
baptize again
with the born Christian born-again sect
I like them I mean we were playing funky
music and everything but there was I was
not happy when they were singing about
Jesus being God you know I was never
singing those songs when it was songs
about God I was singing with them but
when was Jesus being the Son of God I
was like now this is not right and asked
them where is the proof and they said oh
we just have to believe and I said well
this is my future you're talking about
you know where's the proof yes this is
deep this is very powerful where is the
at the same thing for Trinity I said can
you explain to me do you understand
Trinity and and nobody understand so I
said guys this is the main thing of your
religion you can't explain to me is that
you asking a Muslim can you explain to
me the five pillars and they don't know
you know that would be like not inviting
you to become a Muslim if the Muslim
doesn't know why we're doing the faculty
like why it's important for indeed the
foundation of our Deen right so the
treaty is the foundation of Christianity
and we don't know and it's not a concept
that Jesus brought he never taught
abroad never talked about he brought the
pure monotheistic ear oneness of God
that you worship the Creator not the
creation and I said also told them you
know I can't when the witness of Java
was knocking on my door sometimes in the
Philippines I was saying I can't follow
in your Bible there's nothing about this
is between 12 years and 30 years ago
it's called the lost and something very
interesting
it's called the Lost years of Jesus so
there's a guy in the in the US Isolde is
asked to do a basically a journey to
find out what happened of words of Jesus
something very interesting is in some
countries like Nepal and Tibet
there was someone known as ISA who was a
very special man and who is actually
someone was calling to God and it's just
Christ Jesus we call G because Jesus was
not his name yeah well exactly service
scriptures in the Buddhist and the net
by example to talk about a man because
we know ISA our ISA he left at a very
young age because it was already a
threat to the elite and like me all the
prophets of the Sun they left replaced
for a while to come back stronger you
know and this is what happened to ISA I
believe that he went to host country
following the Silk Road and he was
preaching the oneness of Allah to one
one guy to everybody that's why in many
of these countries Nepal even India
some scholars of other religions are
talking about someone that is called ISA
so it's coincide with our belief yeah so
you know there's no contradiction but
they don't know who is ready but
so when I found about Islam when I read
the Quran and I realized oh the Muslim
called Jesus ISA he's just connecting
the dots you know he's just connecting
the dots but of course it's his true
name and actually I even called my first
son ISA because and for and from there
you excluded you went in sincerely
looking for the truth and all these
different religions and from there and
that led you to Islam yeah I mean I it
was the last Ramadan 2012 I I wanted to
to worship got the proper ways so I made
a duets with him and my dua got
fulfilled it ran in front of my window
there was a Naiad about the Quran about
the raining and fizzles whereas many
signs that made me realize God really
wanted to guide in me and I felt you
know very very happy for for his
guidance and then I embraced Islam
online actually I'm resistant after
watching Yusuf Estes sharing his story
why he became Muslim and what was the
difference between the Bible and the
Quran and he made of course it made
sense but the Quran is a true Word of
God and once I was sure but actually I
became Muslim before reading the Quran I
I took my Shahada because the the points
he made in my research really made me
realize for sure the Quran can only be
the word of Allah so I took Machado and
I read the Quran multiple times and Here
I am with each day alhamdulillah and
like I always say look you've been
created for a purpose there's a crater
out there he will guide you to the
purpose start asking the crater alone
for that guidance and you see there's
another story to bring these gems these
stories to motivate you to inspire you
to also seek purpose and then to get to
know purpose and get to know your
Creator and that message is simple
worship the Creator alone not the
creation we're gonna have more Julian
story here in Spain so keep tuning in to
the D show assalamu alaikum